pères ap
de collectionner deux choses
les silences
et les dictionnaires alors ça a eu trois
conséquences sur moi la première
c'est que j'avais le droit de parler
simplement et seulement si j'avais
quelque chose à dire
la deuxième c'est que j'avais le droit
de parler si j'utilisais le mot juste
au risque de passer tout l'après-midi à
chercher dans le dictionnaire les mots
que j'avais pu dire est ce que j'aurais
dû dire et la troisième
c'est que j'avais peur de cette parole
finalement qui avaient ce pouvoir
de me faire passer une après-midi dans
la bibliothèque et c'est là au fond que
j'ai compris
l'écoutent et que j'ai compris aussi ce
que mon père a voulu me transmettre je
crois le pouvoir de la parole
il vient du sénégal de la gambie où
l'oralité est importante
et donc par amour je crois il m'a
transmis le fait que ce pouvoir là cette
parole là avaient de grandes
conséquences
comme peut le dire spider man au fond
grand pouvoir implique de grandes
responsabilités
alors c'est marrant cette invitation
aujourd'hui parce que j'écris j'écris
des livres
et en fait on ne me demande pas de
parler du pouvoir des mots mais bien du
pouvoir de la parole et j'ai remarqué à
chaque fois que j'écris un livre qui
sort je doit l'accompagner d'une parole
on appelle la promotion comme si le
texte ne suffisait pas
il doit être accompagné de notre parole
notre interprétation parce que le texte
ne parle pas il dit ce qu'on veut lui
faire dire
et souvent et cette expression qui
revient
des écrits restent les paroles
s'envolent
comme si les écrits avaient cette
puissance de rester ma mère est juive
donc la tradition de l'écrit mais la
tradition de l'écrit est accompagné par
des interprétations orale les écrits
restent mais les paroles s'envolent
il est là le pouvoir de la parole le
pouvoir de voler comme les oiseaux celle
que nous n'avons pas nous n'avons pas ce
pouvoir de voler une fois que la paroles
s'envolent nous ne pouvons pas la
rattraper
cette part là et d'ailleurs dans les
traditions animistes
d'oralité cette tradition des super
pouvoirs qui ont le droit de vie ou de
mort sur les choses
on peut le remarquer aussi cet
émerveillement
lorsqu'un enfant dit ses premiers mots
ses premières paroles l'émerveillement
des enfants
lorsque l'enfant commence à écrire ses
premiers mots il ya moins
d'émerveillement l'émerveillement est là
mais c'est pas l'extase des parents
devant les premiers mots écrits
la parole à ce pouvoir de vie ou de mort
sur les choses et ce pouvoir aussi de
nous élever scénique ce qui disait
en parlant l'homme dense au dessus des
choses en parlant nous pouvons linou
libéré de situation nous pouvons avoir
un regard sur nos vies un peu de recul
par les le propre de l'être humain ou
dit lacan
mais il complète sa réflexion nous
disons que l'être humain est
profondément morcelé à l'intérieur de
lui-même
et entre la parole et sa pensée il ya
une confrontation
nous sommes obligés de nous rassembler à
l'intérieur de nous-mêmes pour avoir une
parole si nous n'avions pas une parole
commune notre langage intérieur est
incompréhensible et souvent on préfère
justement pointé du doigt nos
différences extérieur plutôt que de
regarder notre propre morcellement
intérieur ce séparatisme intérieur se
réunit avec la parole
voilà un des premiers pouvoir sur nous
mêmes ce rassemblement là
alors oui
la parole
à ce pouvoir de vie ou de mort mais la
parole
ne se contente pas de dire la vérité
elle la craie
et aujourd'hui notre société on peut
remarquer que ce pouvoir de la parole
est mise à mal
parce que dans les institutions
dans notre rythme de vie
dans les discours prononcés par nos
représentants notamment
la parole devient presque une eau tiède
les mots sont vidés de sens
on ne fait plus attention aux prises de
parole entre éléments de langage langue
de bois
parole non tenue
la parole ne capte plus
et puis il y a aussi un autre phénomène
le courage de prendre la parole en
disant une parole un carnet puissante
personnalisé authentique
le courage de dire certains mots
aujourd'hui les discours sont truffés de
figure de style
qui ne permet pas de
d'apprivoiser la parole de l'autre et
des mots qui disent pas tout à fait la
réalité par manque de courage et je
pense à certains mots comme le mot
diversité
quand je vais dans la ddt bibliothèque
trouver les dictionnaires de mon père
le mot diversité ne veut pas dire noirs
et arabes
le mot diversité veut dire nous tous
réunis est différent
et pareil comme les figures de style
vivre ensemble dans ses discours on
glisse vivre ensemble vivre ensemble
c'est oublier que vivre
en tant que
hommes et femmes êtres sociaux c'est
vivre avec l'autre on vit toujours
ensemble
et puis nous avons cette devise
républicaine liberté égalité fraternité
qu'à force de répéter
finalement on en entend plus le sens de
ces mots puissants et précieux alors il
ya cette pensée qui devient molle dans
des discours fleuves et zied et qui
provoque des réactions dangereuse parce
que en réaction à cela la société ne
serait plus à parler
elle se met à hurler
la parole devient hystérie
outrage
vengeance
c'est alimenté aussi par les réseaux
sociaux avec cette parole en 280
caractère qui appauvrit le langage qui
appauvrit la parole et qui appauvrit la
pensée
une atteinte à la démocratie en somme et
au dialogue
et puis enfin il ya ces mots de la
novlangue
qui disent peut être n'importe quoi de
nous avec un ton
toujours vengeurs
[Musique]
assez destructeur qui ne permet pas
d'écouter l'autre
les silences sont importants
les dictionnaires aussi mais les
silences sont importants
et dans cette novlangue
on ne s'écoute en plus la pensée devient
manichéenne
la discorde alors c'est camus qui nous
disait que mal nommer les choses
rajouter du malheur au monde mais mal
parlé rajoute aussi du malheur au monde
le pouvoir de la parole c'est de pouvoir
parler à ses ennemis surtout peut-être à
ses ennemis afin d'éviter la guerre et
le contexte actuel
l'illustrent parfaitement
le pouvoir de la parole
c'est d'éviter que l'on s'entretue
alors finalement
je crois que le pouvoir de la parole met
en exergue nos responsabilités d'êtres
humains
au début était le verbe dit la bible lac
en rajoute au début et l action la
parole se situe précisément entre la
pensée et l'action
mais pour que cette parole soit
impeccable il faut ces silences qui nous
permettent de nous connecter à notre
intimité pour que nos paroles soient
justes et nous ressemble et soit
authentique et incarner
lorsque je suis connecté avec ma parole
que je mente je m'entends bien avec elle
lorsqu'il ya un silence pour pouvoir
être dans l'est dans l'écouté dans les
échanges avec les autres je m'entends
bien avec les autres
cette parole
il faut lui redonner tous ses pouvoirs
elle est fondamentale pour nous pour
dans nos vies elle permet de dire je
suis elle permet de dire mon nom mon
prénom elle permet de dire ma liberté
on l'a vu avec les mouvements mitu cette
liberté cette parole libératrice
lorsqu'il ya l'écoutent
elle permet aussi quelque chose de très
particulier qui est notre conjugaison
nous pouvons passer du je au nous
et cette parole
moi qui suis petite fille de déporté
elle permet aussi la réparation
après la shoah c'est la parole après ses
silences qui a peut-être permis de nous
préparer de la même manière au rwanda
c'est la parole qui a permis de réparer
les victimes nos si l'ensemble d'un pays
lorsqu'il y avait ces réunions entre
victimes et bourreaux
la parole
permet ce lien entre nous elle permet de
dire je ne sais pas peut-être
de laisser de la place au doute et à
l'interprétation
cette parole
elle nous permet
évidemment dans cette relation
dans cet espace
d'avoir un rapport au temps et c'est en
cela qu'elle permet de révéler tout ce
que nous avons dû main cette parole
permet de dire hier
aujourd'hui
demain
et c'est au fond je crois ce pouvoir là
et je dirais même plus compte tenu
de toutes les possibilités que nous
offre la parole c'est que la parole n'a
pas un pouvoir mais des pouvoirs ce sont
ces pouvoirs là qu'il faut transmettre
aux jeunes générations
transmettre
cette clé de leur émotion
transmettre aussi cette civilisation
cette civilité cette urbanité cet
humanisme qui est dans la parole
nous avons cette responsabilité de
transmettre les pouvoirs de la parole
pour que demain nous puissions encore
créé dialoguer échanger construire bâtir
un monde
mais ce monde là est impossible sans la
parole
nous avons je crois le devoir
de transmettre un monde où les femmes et
les hommes
quelle que soit leur couleur de peau
quelles que soient leurs origines
quelles que soient leurs croyances
pourront par la parole
dansaient au dessus des choses
[Applaudissements]